allez
merci Cauet merci Cécile d'être là bon
et ce soir ça va être on va on va revoir
on va on va revoir toutes les séquences
cultes de la Méthode Cauet et c'est vrai
que on s'est eu c'était c'est toi qui
veut dire je le dis c'est koïc qui a eu
l'idée c'est toi qui a qui a fait la
suite derrière c'est NON NON et tu nous
a appelé d'ailleurs avec ses 8 on a dit
on prend on prend direct et on espère en
fait nous voilà on espère que ça va
marcher ce soir parce qu'on espère après
d'en faire d'autres je le sais avec
l'idée tu sais ce que c'est déjà que des
des centaines de milliers de gens
prennent plaisir ce soir parce que je
pense que la Méthode Cauet a été pour
tout âge des il y avait les gamins qui
se planquaient pour regarder quand il
était 23h30 il y avait des gens qui ont
peut-être vécu des des drames et la
méthode que il leur a fait du bien il y
avait des gens qui ont découvert des
artistes parce qu'il y a des pleins
d'artistes vous verrez dans l'émission
de ce soir il y a quasiment les débuts
de Florence Foresti qui qui explosé ou
ou Matt Pokora voilà donc je me dis si
ce soir on fait plaisir aux gens on est
heureux déjà
tu peux dire que tu vas faire plaisir
aux gens on va voir plein de séquences
ce soir est-ce que tu te rappelles tu
avais reçu Stallone c'était un truc de
fou parce qu'en fait il faut savoir que
toutes les plus grandes stars venaient
plus de stars dans La Méthode Cauet en
une émission que toutes les saisons de
Danse avec les stars
mais c'est un truc de fou je te jure que
c'est vrai et moi des fois il m'invite
qu'est-ce que je fous là je comprends
pas il y avait ma porte il y avait
j'avais une porte avec un avec mon nom
dessus sur du se tromper bon vous étiez
amusé à vous mettre des coups de
pression en face à face Stallone network
regarder dis-moi
tu as des muscles
les plaquettes de chocolat tu as des
pectoraux tu en as pas marre de me
copier
[Musique]
OK
Sylvester je vais te regarder dans les
yeux tu me dis à quel moment tu craques
et que tu as peur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour vous raconter la petite histoire de
ça et il avait du retard la la jeune
fille qui le gérait des États-Unis
hurler en designer le reste plus que 10
minutes parce que l'interview c'est très
timé avec les Américains et nous on
avait encore un chat de fiches à faire
avec lui et à un moment donné que Cécile
on s'est fait un clin d'œil on s'est dit
bon on va aller directement à la
clinique de fin qui était celui-là et on
tenté que ça marche parce qu'il aurait
pu dire je joue pas avec vous il ne
savait pas il n'était jamais prévenu à
l'avance de ce qu'on voulait faire parce
que sinon on avait droit à non tout le
temps
il sentait pas mauvais j'ai pas un
souvenir d'odeur
c'est très forte rappel de Will Smith
aussi avec qui tu avais dansé chanter tu
as même fait un bras de fer écoute c'est
vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est important de savoir c'est que
Cauet même si on lui dit il faut que tu
perdes non mais comme moi je le connais
pas
on peut mourir tu peux avoir n'importe
qui on s'en foutait
bravo
en plus
si toi tu avais vécu le kiff de toute tu
as vécu le kiffe que toutes les femmes
rêvent de kiffer de faire tu as eu un
vrai bague avec Will Smith
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je sais pas si vous avez vu ce film ou
lui il était docteur Laure
90 % du trajet et il reste 10 centimes
pour les pour les femmes et je me suis
dit et je voyais tout le monde
et voilà
ils ont rien dit ces équipes tout ça non
alors
ça a hurlé avant ça a hurlé un peu
pendant et quand ils ont vu que tout se
passait bien tout ce qu'il a fait il
avait pas le droit de le faire on nous
avait dit il se laisse pas il chante pas
il ne fera rien d'autre on ne parle que
du film et rien évidemment j'ai fait
tout l'inverse et à la fin comme il
était ravi les équipes ont été ravies
aussi mais il fallait osé y aller quand
même à chaque fois c'est que ça c'est
c'est très très fort tu appelles de 50
Cent ou pas
pour plein de raisons oui ouais est-ce
que il était très colère parce que
l'aéroport lui avait perdu tous ses
bagages donc il est arrivé pas bien du
tout
quand même regardez
[Musique]
que malgré ton visage un peu dur enfin
tu joues les durs pour impressionner
que malgré tout était un mec qui a
beaucoup d'humour
est-ce que tu connais l'histoire de Paf
le chien
[Musique]
[Rires]
il avait oublié ses bagages là c'est bon
les bagages étaient oubliés ça va ils
sont il a l'air bien là il est bien il a
l'air il a l'air très bien
comédiens sont souvent hyper stressés tu
dois être détendu non
ouais ouais
[Musique]
la mâchoire
[Applaudissements]
c'est excellent c'est excellent c'est
excellent
[Applaudissements]
c'est un plaisir de gamin de faire cette
émission parce que tu en as fait
tellement avec nous tu le sais on avait
on avait une trame Cyril dans le public
mais on avait une trame on avait des
trucs de prévu et après on se disait
pourvu que ça marche voilà pourvu que ça
prenne que les invités soient heureux
que j'accepte de jouer le jeu c'est ça
le truc c'est ça et tu non parce que tu
les appelez pas du tout avant ni rien on
pouvait pas parce que si vraiment on
leur avait dit ce qu'on voulait faire
avec eux c'était mort on leur avait dit
il y a des apning peut-être un peu de
déguisement il y aura peut-être de la
perruque et si jamais mais on leur
disait si vous vous sentez un moment
donné un peu ridicule vous inquiétez pas
on coupera on nettoiera et ils avaient
ils avaient cette confiance là on a eu
une séquence avec Robbie Williams où il
avait recomposé une musique avec une
machine à prout
et en le faisant on s'est rendu compte
que c'était pas très glamour et lui-même
aussi à la fin et on a dit voilà
t'inquiète pas cette séquence passera
jamais parce que c'est vrai que c'était
pas très classe en fait
alors il y a Michael Youn aussi tu as
reçu plusieurs fois c'est vrai que
Michael on a fait une petite compile de
Michael j'ai trouvé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
je n'avais pas je n'avais un je suis
dans les stages
tu viens de me le début de
l'émission
à jamais me dire non c'est vrai qu'il
m'a invité je sais j'avais pas déjà pas
trop de promo en plus j'étais pas non
plus débordé et on a pu vivre des
moments ensemble que incroyable j'ai pu
faire la rencontre de Patrick le
moustachu qui est à Noël et c'est vrai
que j'ai une très très belle idée avec
lui depuis on se quitte plus regardé
il est un peu fou il est fougueux mais
la syril aime la vie c'est vous l'amour
matinée pour lui
Patrick ça va tu sais
écoutez monsieur Cauet je vais prendre
le plateau en otage si Patrick ne viens
pas m'embrasser dans les 15 secondes
cette émission va s'arrêter ne faites
pas de con je demande Patrick avec un
hélico et une Renault 19
je déconne pas Cyril ta mère regarde
l'émission non
toi et on ne craint plus rien
il dit qu'il est d'accord
tout de suite
voilà voilà
[Musique]
amoureux d'une personne au centre de ce
public une personne pourvue d'une
moustache bicéphale Patrick je t'aime i
love you
h
et je voudrais dire et voilà bravo
tout était on je suis parti en régie
après j'ai été me déguiser il y a un
plan où on voit Jean-Pierre Mocky vous
regarde
c'est la fin de saison
beau souvenir de télé ah je te jure mais
quelle rigolade parce que vraiment on
sait même pas ce qu'on allait faire mais
pour être très pour être très
transparent il y a plus en télévision
aujourd'hui quasiment que ton émission
ou quelqu'un peut rentrer où tu décides
de prendre une caméra et d'aller
ailleurs tu te rends compte qu'à la
télévision aujourd'hui tu l'as plus ce
qui est un peu dingue d'ailleurs parce
que ce sentiment de liberté tu le vois
avec tes audiences les gens adorent
regarder une émission ou se dire je vais
regarder un truc qui est prévu avec des
débats mais à tout moment tout est
possible
mais on avait l'impression qu'il était
en direct parce que en fait tu laissais
tous les moments de délire et
aujourd'hui je te jure moi je le vois
sur deux émissions il y a plein de gens
il y a plein d'animateurs qui me disent
en fait je fais plein de délires et tout
est coupé je revois l'émission Ça a rien
que vous de Chavanne et lui qui en fait
c'était vraiment les animateurs
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a animé au sens et
mouille à la cheville la cheville pardon
et franchement c'est c'est ça pardon
j'adore Chabat mais ça je pense qu'elle
va nous entrent aujourd'hui ça casserait
un carton ah mais je te dis ouais mais
c'est sûr il y a pas de débat moi je
l'attendais c'était un tout le monde
attendait franchement Gilles c'était le
rendez-vous parce que effectivement il
se passait n'importe quoi et moi je
voulais savoir par rapport au star
américaine est-ce que certaines parfois
étaient capricieuses que certaines
refusaient des trucs etc le staff
toujours le staff en fait c'est ça le
problème c'est à dire qu'on nous
demandait le nombre de pas entre la loge
et le plateau
comment était la loge maquillage comment
machin qu'il fallait ça de l'autre Fidji
de l'eau de machin des trucs des des
listes longs comme le bras et les mecs
ou les nanas arrivés ils étaient hyper
cool moi je me rappelle c'était
à la radio parce que c'était ta cartonné
à la radio et on me disait Cauet c'est
incroyable le matin Cauet Cécile c'est
fou c'est fou c'est fou et à moi quand
tu es arrivé en télé vous avez tout de
suite senti que ça allait prendre ou pas
pas du tout
on a même reçu on a même reçu une lettre
à la sixième mission de TF1 tu te l'aide
très sympathique mais qui disait on en a
signé d'où on est à la moitié pour
l'instant ça ne marche pas préparez-vous
à l'arrêt et bon on s'y était fait et
puis on se disait comme mon cartonné la
radio c'est pas grave on serait resté
des personnalités de radio et à la
septième huitième la magie a pris c'est
passé un truc on s'est lâché un petit
peu plus que je me suis dit quitte à ce
que ça s'arrête c'est ça autant que je
donne tout ce que je savais faire et que
Cécile aussi et bico Cartman tous les
gens on s'est dit on va pousser tous les
curseurs et on va faire ce qu'on aime au
moins on aura fait ce qu'on avait envie
de faire et on pourra pas avoir de
regret et à un moment je sais pas
l'alignement des planètes et d'ailleurs
au début tu avais même un costume je
crois une veste j'avais une veste il
fallait que je vous vois je me souviens
on m'avait demandé à TF1 on m'avait dit
bah voilà la veste on m'avait dit il
faudrait vous voyez les invités j'ai dit
mais je peux pas vous voyez des gens qui
sont venus vider un extincteur la veille
dans mon dans Mission de radio j'ai
essayé une émission il y a des fois il y
a du vous qui se balade mais j'ai pu
après voilà je me suis dit on va faire
plus cool en même temps Cyril sans des
gens comme toi de ce que tu as fait là
ce que tu as montré là ou c'est vraiment
du live non mais c'est vrai le dire il y
a on avait plein d'inités qui se
lâchaient vraiment qui était hyper cool
il va il va vous allez réagir les deux
c'est un truc et c'est vrai que en vrai
je le dis Cauet c'est un énorme talent
mais c'est vrai que Cécile elle avait un
truc aussi c'est que c'est vrai qu'elle
recadrer les interviews donc tu avais
vraiment quelqu'un elle était dans la
déconne et dans l'interview série que le
duo était incroyable et puis c'était
très bienveillant et puis on rigolait de
nos Vannes et les gens nous venaient on
va ner les gens enfin il y avait c'est
une espèce de magie et puis il y avait
un truc que j'aime bien dire ces
derniers temps en interview mais c'est
un peu vrai Cécile elle a cassé un peu
le modèle potiche qu'on avait à la
télévision dans les années 80-90 où il
fallait être belle et puis je ne dis pas
dire grand-chose et et Cécile
[Musique]
salut salut tout le monde salut c'est
Lolo
[Musique]
mais tu peux m'appeler Lolo
salut Greg salut
tu peux dire salut Lolo salut Lolo salut
gros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ûtat
quelle différence y a-t-il entre un 69
et un 51
c'est pas dans le même sens non c'est le
goût
[Applaudissements]
le problème
c'est la CPE en fait on l'a eu non mais
sans rien je te jure c'est incroyable
j'adore cette imitation
moi aussi la liberté aussi de l'émission
et tout c'est est-ce que ça n'était pas
aidé parce que il y avait pas de réseaux
sociaux
revient et ce que je vous souhaite et je
pense que ça pourrait cartonner
évidemment mais avec les réseaux sociaux
est-ce que ce serait pas un modérateur
ou on se freinerait on ferait des
articles c'est un peu c'était un peu à
l'ancienne c'est à dire que le mauvais
papier on se le tapait le lendemain dans
Le Parisien ou ailleurs le fameux la
phrase de Jamel à Dany Minogue on
s'était appelé le lendemain c'était un
peu à l'ancienne quoi c'était l'article
c'était le lendemain dans la presse et
il faisait pas plaisir parce que la
presse c'était beaucoup plus puissante à
l'époque mode donc c'était une oui
aujourd'hui ça serait différent mais
finalement moi je le vois tous les jours
à la radio sur NRJ si on se focalise sur
en France qui vont dire j'ai un trouble
c'est une réflexion grossophobe je
trouve cette personne si on s'arrête
[Rires]
parce que parce qu'en fait on délire
là-dessus depuis 2 jours moi le haters
pour moi il est comme ça il est dans un
truc pas drôle chez lui et il a une et
je pense qu'il est là il fait qu'est-ce
que je vais pouvoir venir alors c'était
en Corée il a pris une pelle dans la
gueule des gens mais maintenant ce qui
se passe le drame c'est pas ça c'est que
tu as le mec qui fait ça tu en as trois
et tu as des abrutis derrière qui vont
faire tout des articles regarde les
articles derrière parce que je peux pas
mettre c'est que les chaînes enfin moi
j'ai vu sur M6 et pk express par exemple
il y en a 60 qui disent du mal et M6 est
en panique et change quelque chose
à 60 ans c'est fou non mais c'est c'est
un truc de fou tu te souviens qu'on
avait chanté ensemble
on a chanté beaucoup de fois ensemble
c'est l'une de ces spécialités mais je
trouve ça très très drôle il s'amuse à
changer les chansons et à mettre des
paroles sur d'autres musiques connues
il s'en aille l'hiver l'été dans le
petit matin frileux mon
vieux on en son vieux père de sur la
paix il a pris mon nom des années
le même motobus
c'était mon vieux c'était mon vieux
le gars avec les paroles c'est
incroyable
[Rires]
c'est pas possible il faut que j'arrête
vraiment tout seul c'est le meilleur
deux pointure
hein
attention
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait comme rigolade
moi de rire j'ai tellement usé de
maquillage moi on avait aussi un truc
qui était génial c'est qu'on avait la
chance de le roder comme tu venais aussi
nous voir des fois le matin à la radio
on avait la chance de rôder des fois des
conneries à la radio et puis on se
disait hey ça a marché quand on faisait
un truc en télé on le faisait avec un
peu plus de moyens mais on tentait de
c'est ça le tu peux c'est ça c'est ça
qui est extraordinaire radio aussi je me
régale à venir mais c'est ce soir à la
méthode cohérent de la Méthode Cauet
vous allez regarder Jean-Michel ah bah
oui parce que moi en plus j'étais
particulièrement amoureux d'une des
danseuses il y avait des danseuses
je suis sorti on est danseuse mais qui
m'a foutu dans la merde après parce que
je devais faire le Bachelor sur C8 bah
oui et après elle a appelé voici en
disant Jean-Michel maire le Bachelor
c'est une blague c'est mon mec et en
fait c'est à cause d'une des danseuses
de Cauet
Sandy Sandy
je viens pas non c'est qui c'est qui
l'invité que vous avez le plus kiffé
plus gros événement c'est quoi
bah oui vous l'avez montré tout à
l'heure mais c'est Stallone mais mais
parce que j'avais aussi un autre un
autre truc dans ma tête moi je suis un
fan de la télé populaire et de la radio
populaire et quand j'avais dans mon
fauteuil des gens qui m'ont fait vibrer
quand j'étais gamin j'étais heureux de
faire rire Philippe Bouvard j'étais
heureux de faire rire Jean-Pierre
Foucault j'étais heureux de faire rire
Patrick Sébastien parce que je me disais
les gamins que je voyais dans le poste
de la télé de mon père en Picardie ils
étaient là et ils riait de mes blagues
et voir Philippe Bouvard qui bougeait
comme ça je me disais voilà il y a
j'étais heureux des deux autant les
grandes stars que les stars populaires
de la télé c'est qu'il a invité le plus
relou tu as eu antipathique plus il y a
pas eu vraiment de l'antipa
avec Lio tu en as parlé il y a quelques
jours ouais Lio savait pas été parce que
elle s'était elle avait fait un truc
qu'on aime pas trop moi je suis on est
assez solidaire avec les équipes et Miko
Cartman des fois il y avait des trucs
très drôles bon des fois il y avait des
trucs qui étaient pas bien travaillés et
cette fois là il faut un truc qui
n'était pas extraordinaire mais on se
disait c'est pas grave il peut y avoir
un coup de génie à un moment donné on
coupera au montage ou pas et on voyait
Lio du coin de l'oeil à mon avis on a
dit mais il y a un problème elle a dit
ouais c'est pas drôle ce qu'ils font
alors en fait elle a coupé la parole
parce que vous faites c'est nul c'est
pas drôle ah ouais et voilà et là c'est
horrible t'imagines les deux ils sont
déguisés ils sentent eux-mêmes que c'est
pas le sketch du siècle mais en plus ça
ça vient les arrêter net il y avait Eric
et Ramzy qui était dans le fauteuil donc
ça met un peu une ambiance bon et puis
voilà on a dit au revoir très élégamment
à Lyon en lui disant que c'était par là
mais honnêtement je préfère penser au je
sais pas 700 800 invités qui ont été
incroyables que les 5 6